our final talk this morning is by Ken
Miller from Columbia University and
people speak about the regime of sensory
particle computation whose AI balance
and the normalization thanks so I'm
gonna tell you about work that has been
done by particularly by these people Dan
Rubin who is a grad student with me
who's now neurology fellow of some sort
at Harvard and Yoshi Ahmadi and it was a
postdoc with me and is now on the
faculty at Oregon just all of these that
you can't ask for worked as easy when
you have wonderful people who do it and
also I may mention some work we've done
on how this circuit explains the
stimulus driven suppression of
variability and that's been done by all
of us including young hennequin and
mattelli angle at Cambridge so there's
really I'm going to be addressing two
issues today that are interlinked one is
power excitation and inhibition and
inhibition that's a psycho ballast to
keep the network stable without firing
great saturation and I'll explain why I
think there's not firing great
saturation playing a role in the
stability in a minute and the other is
how does cortex modulate response keying
and this was actually so long and that
there's a lot of evidence at least in
there for that selectivity you're tuning
for the properties of the stimulus
orientation Direction spatial frequency
and vision are largely determined by the
feed-forward inputs these different
groups and here in s1 the same thing but
that the cortical circuit is modulating
the response gain to things like
surround suppression normalization
attention so how does that happen and
the answer I'm gonna propose is that the
recurrent dynamics yields inhibitory
stabilization by what I call a loose AI
balancing and I'll tell you what that
means and that balancing that yields the
observed nonlinear patterns of cortical
game module
and normalization okay so so let's begin
with what what do I mean by what are
what are the examples of how cortical
gay modulation works so the classic
example is shown here from John Reynolds
this is a neuron in v4 that you put a
face and it's receptive field it gives
you a nice big response you put a house
and receptive field it gives me a much
smaller response you put both in the
receptive field at the same time and it
gives you an intermediate response
something more like the average than the
sum of the two responses so that's a
very sublinear summation and then it
goes on to say if you attend to one of
the other your response moves toward
that but I want to focus on this initial
part where you're getting a sub linear
summation more like the average and the
sum of the two individual responses but
and this is seen in many other phenomena
and it's even been shown to happen
you don't know where this is happening
it might be already in the inputs to the
piece of cortex you're recording from
but it's been shown to happen in a
particular piece of cortex namely v1 by
NASA and Reynolds who added an
optogenetic and a visual stimulus in
monkey v1 which so the two stimuli the
optogenetic shouldn't change what's
coming up from below so you begin push
it out linearly but you still see this
up with information now I should add
that mark has stared and John mon-sol
have done the same permanent mouth and
they seem to find linear summation and
we have a possible explanation of that
within the framework of this theory at I
can tell you about at the end but so
it's maybe some exceptions but mostly
you see the sub linear summation and so
now to talk about how this depends on
the the input drive I just have to make
sure everybody's on the same page and
those what the contrast of a visual
stimulus is just a light dark difference
relative to the mean and what it really
represents to us is the strength of the
feed-forward input the higher the
contrast of a stimulus the higher the
firing rate of the LGN inputs to be one
so we'll use contrast to mean strength
54 bit input and so although moderately
strong stimuli add sub linearly low
contrast stimuli add linearly or maybe
super linearly this junk from can
britain in study of empty cells we put
two different motion stimuli in the
receptive field of the of the empty cell
and when they were both high contrast
that this is the sum of the two
responses to the individual stimuli and
this is the actual response when both
were shown together so you can see when
when they're both high contrast you've
got a sub linear summation less than the
sum of the two individually but when
they were what they called mixed
contrast meaning either one was of low
contrast or both were of low contrast
you've got a much more linear summation
and what they didn't tease out was when
they were both very low whether it might
be super linear which I'm going to tell
you why I might think it is
and then they plotted the ISO response
contours and they changed from and I may
get these I would get these backwards
but concave to convex or is it vice
versa anyways they changed from one to
the opposite and and in our model our
model is going to look just like this
and on our model that's going from sub
linear here to super linear over here
but it doesn't prove that the MT is
going all the way to super linear here
at low contrast okay so and this is also
seen in other areas that scene in MST
where you add vestibular and visual
inputs you get the sub linear summation
for strong but linear for weak inputs
okay and the winner take all this this
summation becomes winner-take-all four
unequal strength stimuli and that's
illustrated here from material Karen Dee
Dee's lab where you see here's the
response of all the neurons plotted as a
function of their preferred orientation
in each little plot and so here is
showing horizontal stimuli so if you
show a 25 percent contrast horizontal
stimulus here's the cells that before
horizontal responding most strongly show
25 percent vertical here's the cells
that prefer vertical responding most
strongly show both at the same time you
get the sub linear summation but if one
of them stronger than the other it's as
if only the strong one was there and it
turns out this cross orientation
suppression is not a good example
because it probably a lot of this is
going on in the algae on inputs and not
in v1 but the same thing as seen in
monkey
and is it sort of ubiquitous enough that
we suspect it might be a cortical
property though it hasn't really been
proven that it's happening in a
particular piece of cortex okay so
another way that stimuli add or modulate
each other's gain so so you think of
that as you know you show one stimulus
you've got a response but you show
another stimulus it modulates the gain
to the first response because you keep
your same tuning so that that's you can
think of this as a gain modulation how
are things adding and the idea is that
when they're moderately strong they tend
to suppress each other so they tend to
something really odd but when they're
weak and then they tend to ignore each
other lineally odd or maybe even as I'll
show you now facilitate so what's the
round suppression this now instead of
adding two stimuli in the receptive
field we're going to add in the receptor
field and outside the receptive field
and so this is from David Firsters lab
and the grading is drifting and this is
showing the spike rate over one cycle of
the grading this is a simple cell so it
fires on half the cycle and here's the
blank stimulus and now you go from two
degrees to 20 degrees this is not to
scale and the response is greatly
suppressed and that suppression depends
on the sender and the surround having
matched orientations this surround
suppression is seen at least across
almost every visual every visual area
that's been studied and probably in
other sensory areas as well we don't
know and where it has been studied if
when you make the sender stimulus low
contrast then this around either
facilitates or more weakly suppresses
rather than suppressing strongly so
that's another example of you know weak
stimuli tend to facilitate or ignore
each other strong stimuli suppress each
other yeah so just to show you this I'll
just show you one example from material
Karen Dinis lab and what he did was he
he recorded from a cell in monocular
mouth v1 and he activated callosum
fibers from the other side so he was
activating cells that were lateral and
v1 over in the binocular region lateral
to the cell in the monocular region they
were recording from and so in this way
they could be pretty sure they were
linearly adding input you have one
visual input
one lateral and put the top activated
oxygen ethically and what they saw was
that so this is the contrast of the
visual stimulus that's activating the
center and this is different levels of
the light stimulus this activating this
around and you see when the senator
stimulus is weak the surround enhances
the response but when the senator
stimulus is strong this around
suppresses the response and another
example of the same thing if you make a
size tuning curve so you make fried a
single contrast that was showing how
having Center in surround of different
strengths but now you have a single
contrast across Center and surround and
you just change the size and you map out
a length tuning curve and you say where
does that peak before you starts around
suppressing that's called the summation
field size and that summation field size
is bigger at low contrast it shrinks
with contrast shrinks with the strength
of input drug meaning for a weekend puts
stimuli out here in the surround that
are facilitating you for strong inputs
they're suppressing you so that's a very
nonlinear effect and and that's shown
here where the ratio at some of this
summation field sides at some low
contrast over some high contrast to have
to be bigger than one this is from
monkey from Bob Shapley's lab so you
have two kinds of nonlinearities one is
the sub linear summation but the other
is that the nature of the summation
changes with the strength of the input
which wouldn't happen in in a linear
system okay so those are the sorts of
gain modulation phenomena that the model
I'm going to tell you about will explain
so let me tell you about the model that
what we call the stabilized super linear
network and just to prime you your
whoops well so much for priming you
you're gonna I'm going to show you that
there's two regimes and weakly coupled
in a strongly coupled regimes and in the
strongly coupled regime you have a
loosely bound loose balance of
excitation inhibition and I'm going to
contrast that with tight balance okay so
where are we what's the superlinear and
the super linear stabilized network it's
that the individual neurons have a super
linear input output function so what's
shown here is liq TV and david first ER
they measured the membrane potential in
30 millisecond bins and they looked at
the firing rate in the same
I think they average over like five bins
so you get you know once by zero spikes
one spike - spike three spikes in 530
millisecond bins give you these
different firing rates and the actual
data is very noisy is shown by these
grey dots but that's because you have
four you know you can imagine for a
given fixed rate you have some porcelain
variability and how many spikes you get
but if you average and voltage bends to
try to get out what's the mean rate for
each voltage it's very it's a blue dots
which are very well fit by this power
law which is a power of in this case
about 2.8 and in general different cells
they find it's between two and five so
it's an expansive non-linearity a power
greater than one why do you get this you
could show very generally that when
you're when you're mean input is sub
threshold or peri threshold so that
you're not you're not integrating up
towards the mean that's way above
threshold that would make you fire like
a clock you'd be integrating up you'd
hit you'd fire like a clock but instead
you're firing the fluctuations are
driving get a spike that makes you fire
in a more potent way which is how cortex
fires so we think cortex for various
reasons is firing on the fluctuations
not on the mean when you are firing on
the fluctuations you get this power law
input-output function the reason is
basically because the fluctuations have
some bell-shaped curve and as you move
the mean over the portion of that curve
that's above threshold is growing super
linearly and that's basically your
firing rate now a couple things to
notice about this one is this is across
the full range this is an in essence
eyes get v1 this is across the full
range of visual stimuli you can show
this cell including the most optimal
cell that drives as hard as you possibly
can and so of course we know eventually
the cell has to saturate but you don't
see that in the normal dynamic range so
we're going to just assume that there's
no saturation in order to understand how
the circuit keeps itself stable here
without using saturation to stabilize
itself and right so what does this do
for you well actually before I do that
let me just say that what I'm really
going to assume is that from the input
the you know the weights there
and put the weights times the rates plus
the feed-forward inputs their rates from
the input to the firing rate is a is a
super linear function now what I'm
showing you here is from the membrane
potential of the firing rate from the
input to the membrane potential might be
sublinear if you have synaptic
depression or spike great adaptation
might be super linear if you have
synaptic facilitation or dendritic
integration that's it's not only er what
I have to assume is that whatever this
input to membrane potential mapping is
it's not so sublinear that it turns this
around and makes it sub linear so long
as the net stays super linear we're
going to be okay all right and then the
last thing so what does this do for you
it means that your game how much does
your firing rate change for a change in
your input is great it's just the slope
of this curve and that is monotonically
growing as the as the cell and the
network get more activated so what does
that do for you well that means you have
increasing effective synaptic strengths
in your network what I mean by effective
synaptic strength basically when I
jiggle the presynaptic rate how much
does the postsynaptic rate jigglin
responds that's the product of two terms
it's the product of the synaptic
strengths how much how much input do I
inject and again how much does my great
jiggle in response to that input or
another way to think of it if I
linearize about a fixed point this
product is what I get from my effective
weights in a linearized system so so as
the gain goes up my cells are more and
more sensitive to their input and so I
effectively have stronger and stronger
coupling and so what does this do for
you
well imagine now I have a network of
excitatory cells in red and nubret or e
cells and blue they have some coupling
to each other each one's receiving some
feed-forward input and first let's
consider very weak activation so the
gain is going to zero so if I'm very
weakly activated then I have very weak
effective synaptic strengths and the key
thing is that if I assume that the
network does not have a that as the
feed-forward input goes to zero the
network activity goes to zero it doesn't
have a self maintained high state then
feed forward activation just requires
one of these weak synapses but recurrent
activation requires a feed-forward
synapse to activate the cortical cell to
activate the recurrent we
so the recurrence comes in at two or
more weeks in Epps's and so if they gain
if they send out there's a week enough
if the gain is small enough just like
x-squared is much less than X if X is
small enough the the recurrence becomes
very weak compared to the feed-forward
input and so you get into a weekly
couple they're almost uncoupled regime
and therefore when I show two stimuli
they're feed-forward inputs just add
their network doesn't change that very
much and then I put it through a
superlinear input/output function and so
I should get more than this sum of the
responses to the two stimuli by
themselves responses should add super
linearly but now what if I go to a
stronger activation regime well so the
effective strengths are getting stronger
and stronger the more I activate and so
the recurrent contribution grows
relative the feet forward and becomes
dominant and in particular the e2e
connections become effectively strong
enough that the network the edie network
would become potentially unstable by
itself basically if the if the e cells
fluctuated up by themselves they
recurrence that would recruit they would
be so sensitive to it that they would
keep going up so you have a potential
instability but you can show that if you
have sufficiently strong feedback
inhibition and the actual condition for
a two population model just E and I
without more cells is that the the
product of the two negative feedback
terms is bigger than the product of the
two positive feedback terms and in
addition if the inhibitory time constant
is sufficiently small relative to the
excitatory time constants then you can
prove the network will go to a stable
fixed point and it won't run away in a
practice you find even in big networks
if you sort of make the equivalent of
these conditions true the network stays
typically stay stable so but how does it
stabilize so that tells you that you
will stabilize what does it have to do
to stabilize and what we can show is
that in order to stabilize the network
has to balance the recurrence has to
largely cancel the feed-forward input
meaning the e and the I are balancing
the canceling each other leaving a
residual that grows sub linearly as a
function of the net feed-forward input
so if the feed-forward input is growing
you know here's the growth of the
feed-forward input
the net input after the cancellation
maybe it's going is the square root of
that or the cube root of that so much
much more slowly so you're losing most
of the feed-forward input that you add
as you add more stimuli and so what that
means is that the network responses and
this I can maybe talk more about offline
but basically it grows as the one over N
power but then it gets raised to the end
so you might think it comes out linear
but for many purposes it comes out sub
linear and so you end up basically
canceling most when you add a second
stimulus you add you end up canceling
most of the seats forward input and you
end up getting something on your
summation
so the balancing is giving you the sub
linear summation basically so let's see
how that works so here's our fine
equation so R is the vector of all of
the firing rates of all of our neurons
and what we're saying is in the steady
state that firing rate is the input
raised to the N where the input is the
weight matrix times the rates that's a
vector of recurrent inputs plus the
feed-forward inputs which I'm going to
call G which is the shape think of the
Jesus being ordered one so this one
receives one this one receives 1/2
that's where we cease to and then see
for contrast which is not going to scale
up the input by changing the scalar
while keeping the G shape the same ok so
and then to give it dynamics we just
make it approach at steady state with
first-order dynamics so for weak input
this is what I showed you what I said to
you before that if if C is very very
small we can expand this as CG plus W
times R which is CD plus W times R and
so you end up with just a feed-forward
input what you want you get from the
feed-forward input alone and everything
involving W everything involve a
recurrence comes in at higher order and
C so if c is small enough just become
negative to be small and your
feed-forward dominated so and here's
what that looks like so very for very
small see here's my feed-forward input
going up and here's my total recurrent
input it stays smaller than my
feed-forward input and then my
excitatory response I think I'm using N
equals 2 here it's just the square of
the sum of these two and so here's the
super linear growth
their response but now that's that's
this little box here but as I increase
the strength of C and I get into the
strongly coupled regime something very
interesting happens the recurrent here's
the feed-forward input growing the
recurrent input turns around becomes
negative and grows it almost the same
rate as the feed-forward input so you're
canceling most of the feed-forward input
and the net is growing like this which
is it is growing because when you square
it you see the growth of the firing rate
which is the square of this dashed line
but you're you're growing very
subliminally it turns out this response
versus see there's two regimes one grows
up linear like this one will eventually
grow linearly so I'm showing you the sub
linear regime but when you add two
different stimuli two different shapes
of stimuli they typically add sub
linearly so but the main thing I want
you to take home here is to see how
without there's no fine-tuning this is
just you put it in that regime where
it's going to be stable where I told you
we can guarantee it'll be stable this is
what it has to do to stay stable the
dynamics make this happen we don't tune
anything the recurrence just cancels the
people would input leaving a very slowly
growing sub linearly growing residual
another thing so actually let me let me
start with the left so as we increase
the input record and this happens to be
for a ring architecture but you see the
same thing for any architecture it's
very generic to this model with the
power law and put up with functions
here's the total feed-forward input that
the neurons receive to the excitatory
neurons and rather to the inhibitory
neurons in blue and here's the total
recurrent input that they receive to the
excitatory or the inhibitory neurons and
so you see for very weak input then as
advertised you're receiving much more
most of you and put his feed-forward you
very small amount of recurrent but at
about the point where the excitatory
network goes unstable as it turns out
you get a crossing and then the
recurrent input comes to dominate after
that and furthermore if you look just at
the recurrent input and say what
percentage of it is excitatory look at
the excitatory input over the excitatory
plus inhibitory input that is
monotonically decreasing as you drive
the network harder and harder basically
both inhibition and excitation sub some
sub linearly they both not even the one
of them but the inhibition something
super
to make excitation sub-sub some
sub-linear but they both sums up
linearly but the inhibition has to go
faster than the excitation to keep
things stable and that's what you're
seeing here the inhibition the
inhibitory firing rates are going faster
yeah Peter in this here they do yeah but
it doesn't depend on that yeah except
that you'll get roughly the same results
yes but the the the the contrast
response curve or the input strength
response curve will be linear in that
case it won't turn over a lot saturate
but for many purposes you'll still get
some of the information so here I'm
assuming that everybody is by a
physically identical he and I they all
have exactly the same power law that I'm
doing that basically to say you get all
these effects without without making the
inhibition have some special biophysical
properties but if you change them you
won't won't fundamentally change this
story because the basic story is about
going unstable and what it takes to
stabilize well then you can lose
stability yeah you can lose the building
that case sure okay and this should be
compared with from Dan Feldman's lab
where they optogenetic li excited semi
cells and recorded the charge received
by the non optically excited cells and
the harder they grow things up
genetically the more this ratio went
down and halala des nick has recently
shown exactly the same thing in Mouse v1
where this decreases both with contrast
and with stimulus on which the model
also predicts for I'm not gonna get to
tell you half of what I want to do but
let me just compare this to the tightly
balanced network so we can show that
this transition there's a dimensionless
parameter which we call alpha which is
basically the typical strength of the
current weights times the typical
strength of feed-forward weights raised
to the N minus 1
power this transition occurs when this
parameter is order one so and and you
can find an expansion for the firing
rate in the strongly coupled regime
which is here's the term that cancels
the feed-forward input you applied W to
this you get negative the feed-forward
input so this term cancels the
feed-forward input and the residual goes
as C to the one over and it grows up
linearly with the feed-forward input and
it actually is of this form you have C
over typical weight size this gives you
the units of rate and then here's this
is order one J is just the normalized W
and G is the normalized feed-forward
input with the C taken out and the next
order term is order alpha to the
negative one over n but where this
transition happens when alphas order 1
meaning this term is the same order of
magnitude as this term they're both
comparable to each other and that's what
we're gonna mean by loose balance that
what's left over after the cancellation
is comparable in size to the things that
cancel and note that this first term is
a linear function of the feed-forward
input it has to be because it's
canceling the feed-forward input it has
to be linear in the feed-forward input
to cancel it the second term gives you
the net input after cancellation so this
is a new loose balance and the fact that
it's a loose balance is what allows you
to have nonlinear response properties if
it was a tight balance meaning that if
this term was tiny compared to this term
so what's left over is tiny compared to
the things to cancel then that means
that this is basically your firing rate
and this is linear in the input and this
is negligible and so your firing rate is
linear in the input you can't get not
only responses so it's only by loosely
balancing that you get whoops that you
get this nonlinear term right did you
get this nonlinear term that allows you
to have not only response properties so
let's compare that to tight balance
which is when alpha goes to infinity and
this is the balanced Network solution of
van riebeck ensemble in ski and Granard
studied and what they showed was that
when the inputs were really big they
would cancel each other to leave
something really small something
negative a small they should you'll get
tight balance and it's a seminal study I
don't mean to say it's not but I want to
say that it's
the right regime for cortex if Seminole
because it showed us that the dynamics
could do the balancing without any
fine-tuning among other reasons but so
what they assumed was all of these
parameters were of order square root of
K where K with some big number the
number of excitatory inputs received by
an excitatory so and so if you each of
these the square root of K then this it
goes as KT alpha goes as K to the N over
2 and so this term is precisely 1 over
square root of K so this is which is
what they found for their second order
term and this is K was big so this was
negative to be small compared to this
they had tight balance but they had only
linear response so this is actually the
exact same expansion that you get for
the balanced Network the difference is
we're already getting the balancing when
alphas order 1 not 1 else is going to
infinity and that's what's giving us all
the nonlinear behavior that looks like
cortex
so to summarize well let me I think
you've got this so let me just try to
push through a little bit is the
external input what receivers cortex
really in is the external input greater
than the net input after cancellation
which would be tight balance or is it
comparable
well when cortex is silenced to reveal
the ceramic input the LGN induced
voltage response is typically a third to
a half of the net input when cortex was
intact it's not ten or a hundred times
bigger which is what type balance would
predict that you take these big things
and cancel to make a small net certainly
if you look at the excitatory
conductance the conductance after you
silenced cortex is about thirty to forty
percent of the net conducted excitatory
conductance with cortex in tech so it's
the external input and the net are
comparable and actually that doesn't
contradict hypothesis I think about so I
think I'm in a mistake there but at any
rate the important thing is that when
you look at the total excitatory input
that the peak excited to a conductance
with cortex intact is on the order 60
250 Pico amps input resistance on the
order 150 200 mega ohms that means that
the excitatory conductance is enough to
depolarize you by nine to thirty
millivolts which is completely
comparable to the 20 millivolt distance
to threshold wears tight balance means
you've got to be orders of magnitude
bigger than the distance in threshold so
all of the data says we're no loose
balance regime the input is comparable
to threshold the external input is
comparable to the net input and I was
going to do some calculations of the
mean and variance but I'm not going to
do that because I'm out of time ok let
me go back if I can right this is with
outside nothing this is the total
excitatory conductance down here okay so
I'm gonna obviously skip this and I'm
going to give you my conclusion slides
so what are the answers that explain it
turns out given simple models of
connectivity that the connectivity falls
off a distance of retinotopic space or
in feature space and explained sub
linear summation that becomes linear or
super linear at the stimulus weakens one
thing I didn't say is that I don't know
where spontaneous is so for very very
weak for almost zero input I have super
linear stronger it becomes sub linear
maybe spontaneous is around the
transition and so we can only get down
to linear or maybe cortex can get all
the way to such a super linear we don't
know but at least it's going in the
right direction suits sub linear to
linear as as things get weaker and it
becomes winner-take-all four unequal
strength stimuli we get all the surround
suppression phenomena facilitation for a
weak center summation field size expands
as the stimulus weakens other phenomena
the same model explains the suppression
of the shared component of variability
with increasing stimulus tracks
basically once you're in the strongly
coupled regime as you're driving
networks more strongly it becomes more
strongly inhibition stabilized meaning
if you linearize about the fixed point
you're the real parts of your leading
eigenvalues are being pushed more
negative that means the leading modes
are fluctuating less and if your
connectivity has some structure space
smoothly structure then those leading
modes have some smooth structure so they
represent correlated activity and their
fluctuations are getting suppressed by
the increasingly strong stabilization
and various experimental tests in our
2015 paper we predicted that there were
standing waves with a preferred
frequency that shrinks are a period that
shrinks with increasing contrast and
found that to be true and ferret be one
we just published a paper
that tells me my 30 minutes are up so we
just published a paper with Chris Peck
and Dave Leo that in Mt just as you have
you know the the you prefer a bigger
stimulus in in retinotopic space for it
for weak stimuli than you do for
stronger stimuli same should be true in
feature space if you can show many
directions at once you should prefer a
wide set of directions at low contrast
and a narrower set of directions at high
contrast the watch that should start
suppressing you and that's just what
they saw and the shrinking GI ratio with
increasing stimulus strength as I showed
you and so the conclusion is that all of
these things are the outcomes of
stabilization by inhibition inhibition
or loose balancing a recurrent network
with a destabilizing or superlinear
input-output function and I'll stop
there in fact the people who did the
work thank you
[Applause]
when the cell is by kiko super-tiny
because there is the transit
environments with an exhibition on
inhibition and in the regime that you're
using your using ratings optimized
ratings where excitation is out of phase
with additional services so how much can
we save from the type of regime as
prediction of what happens with natural
sees okay so your everything I've shown
you has been about steady-state response
is not about transient responses and I
think you're basically asking about what
happens with dynamic transient responses
and I have to say I don't know the
answer if that's something we need to
study so come on what timescale do you
do the balancing what happens you know
so yeah we need to study that but I
don't have any good answers yeah I get
functional understanding of what this
whole thing might be I mean there's a
lot of phenomena and they go in the
right direction let's let's just accept
that you've got the right model for v1
or for cortex let's say a canonical VI
balancing circuit so you know we have
concepts lying around like divisive
normalization helps to take out
multiplicative factors and signals that
are nuisance factors you have to kind of
Schwartz the second shell the idea this
is a more complicated normalization
circuit I mean I can't I can to my head
see why you would want to do all these
things like I have a good answer for
that right yeah sure has a good answer
for that
so yeah sure had us figured out at
Oregon I don't have anything to do with
it that he takes the shortened and
Simoncelli model which is it's a model
of natural scenes it's called a Gaussian
scale mixture and so you basically if I
remember right you assume that there's a
positive scale multiplying a Gaussian
distribution that explains the
distribution and natural scenes and then
you're trying to infer you're trying to
get rid of the scale and infer the
underlying variable independent of scale
so independent of variations in contrast
and when Yasir Yasir has done is added
noise to that model and when he adds nor
is he gets these transitions so in other
words they that model predicts the norm
the strongly coupled regime behavior
once he had noise he gets both regimes
as he makes the family factor weak so
the purpose of the circuit is to do that
type of function but in regional regimes
of high and low noises that have you
would segment you just said that that
would be good I mean at least Yasha has
got a nice theory that matches this
which is which is exactly what you just
said no is that why I don't know but
it's one nice story about why yeah wait
wonder the curse because more long range
just that just that things fall off I
get the surround suppression in
rent-a-thug space I mean the circuit
knows about retinotopic space because
things fall off with retinotopic
distance if if things didn't fall off
with retton's up your distance it
wouldn't know anything about written
topic space except maybe from the
feed-forward input but the basic
normalizing properties and the
transition between regimes is going to
happen regardless of that we may not get
the same surround suppression phenomena
contrack and inputs very fast with
thanks because it is much smaller than
the intrinsic yeah it doesn't mean
basically in the tight balance your your
your eigen values are going to negative
infinity and so you're becoming
infinitely fast here the eigenvalues are
negative so you're faster than the
membrane time constant are comparable to
the membrane time constant but you're
not going to zero and so for example I
don't know if massimo is still around
but in there is yeah so massimo showed
that when you when you silence thalamus
v1 activity decays in about 10
milliseconds about a something like a
cellular tower synaptic time constant
the model does the same thing it has
very fast response and actually that's
in a paper we've just submitted with
Guillaume and Matea about the
suppression of variability we show that
there
a couple of other models of the
suppression of variability one is a
stimulus suppresses chaos and other is
that you have you're wandering between
multiple fix points and the stimulus
pins you to one of them and we showed
that in both of those the the onset of
the stimulus the the suppression of
variability after the onset and their
recovery of variability after the offset
is much slower than the cellular time
constant whereas in our case it's
roughly comparable well or two or three
to it but it's in the same order of
magnitude and that that seems to match
the data that the the suppression is
fast and so this gives you the fast
oppression for example the ring
architecture but that's that's not
really important please join me in thank
you
[Applause]